problem that I give to my calculus
students every time I teach calculus we
spend a lot of time doing it with Hefty
techniques my students at the end of the
exerciser I hope sveza doesn't give this
on an exam and then I asked them would
you like to see a three to five wine
solution that a smart fifth grader would
understand and of course they all want
to sit so let's see how it goes
there is a river and it's a hot October
day in California about 200 years ago
there is
a poor cow she is broken its leg and
cannot move and the cow is very thirsty
the cow is six kilometers from the river
all right so I'm going to call this
point B here
a farmer four kilometers from be down
the river so maybe somewhere here call
this a the farmer himself is two
kilometers away from the river the
farmer has a buck so what does the
farmer need to do
to walk to the river somewhere
dip the bucket into the water
and then walk to the car
so walking to the river and then walking
to the car but it's very hot and these
are very long distances right remember a
b by itself is already four kilometers
and so on and the farmer has many many
choices
so which point on the river should he
aim for
to have his walk as short as possible
so which is this point x here
right yeah just minimize the walk right
right
this feels like it should be simple
simple that's right it looks super
simple and so my calculus students get
to work they need a variable so how can
I think about this point x well I guess
if I know how far it is from point A I'm
just going to denote this by Little X I
will locate it but if this is X then the
remainder to be will be 4 minus X
and immediately you're thinking of the
Pythagorean theorem there you go
right and so what is the distance that
the farmer will make F X Plus XC right
so you want to make those two hypotenuse
as short as possible well together add
it up not individually
so we have these two right triangles
everyone is happy the first hypotenuse
will be square root of 2 squared plus x
squared plus this hypotenuse x c will be
6 squared plus what was that 4 minus X
Quest and what do we want we want to
minimize this so minimum for which X so
which X is going to make this Mass
minimum
before I start I'm going to make some
obvious observations which actually
would need proof but I want to simplify
this already horrendous calculus
solution
I mean Brady would the farmer go
somewhere here do you think that would
be the shortest of course not I mean
it's ridiculous right or somewhere here
he probably would have to go between a
and b and I will leave it to the reader
to verify why this should happen so that
means that X by itself ranges between 0
to 4. can be negative can be more than
four so I'm gonna write this here just
to help the calculus solution all right
so how how what do we do with Calculus
we say that this is a function f of x
and we are going to take its derivative
if you don't know calculus just close
your ears relax drink coffee and join us
in two minutes
I'll see you later
okay I'll stay
all right so square root derivative
you're going to have a fraction two of
the same square root underneath and on
top I have to take the inside derivative
which is 2x all right we are done with
half of that derivative and we do
something similar for the other square
root we develop a fraction to the same
square root in the denominator and then
I have to take the inside derivative
which is a bit more complicated it's 2 4
minus X and then there is a negative in
front Okay and then we will humanely get
rid of those two's here and if you
continue in the standard calculus we are
going to get in trouble
it's just not easy to solve this but I
am going to proceed in a
interesting way I'm going to say when is
this derivative non-negative
I'm going to push things out of here so
that will be X over this radical
plus actually there is no plus anymore
this minus goes to the other side with a
plus the other fraction is here okay
now we would like to get rid of those
radicals but inequalities are very
tricky so they really want things to be
positive but we made them positive
because that X was between 0 and 4 which
means that both those numerators are
positive denominator is a positive we
can square both sides no problem so I'm
going to square x squared over 2 squared
plus x squared when is that greater than
4 minus x squared 6 squared plus 4 minus
x squared as you notice I'm actually not
multiplying things out because I've done
this a hundred times and I know how to
simplify so keep it compact for now and
then since everything is positive I'm
going to cross multiply 6 squared x
squared plus 4 minus x squared x squared
all right so we're done this way and now
crossing the other way 2 squared 4 minus
x squared plus x squared 4 minus x
squared now the key step why do they
keep everything so compact
because it looks to me
I can simplify can I how about I can
just get rid of those
they're the same Miracle occurs now
this 4 and this 36 would give you a 9.
all right so the only survivors here are
nine x squared and four minus x squared
and again no need to multiply through
because I can just take square root on
both sides and all of those little terms
are still positive so what this turns
out to be is 3x on the Left 4 minus X on
the right all right when is this
happening move the X to the other side
4X greater than or equal to four x
greater than or equal to one you know
the calculations didn't seem too
complicated but it's because I made
drastic shortcuts if you don't know
about them this could be a nightmare to
solve especially on an exam
attenuate what did we show we showed
from a calculus Viewpoint that the
derivative
is greater than or equal to zero
exactly or if and only if x is greater
than or equal to 1. okay what does this
mean for a function we've practically
solved the problem but let me review if
in fact this is the x-axis right and our
interval is from 0 to 4. I know that F1
from one on the function my function
will increase the original function not
the derivative that's exactly what this
relationship means so so the function
has to increase like that
so the distance for the farmer if he
goes beyond that point one will actually
be increasing the total distance but I
said that this condition here is if and
only if so the sign switch if we go the
other way around and the function will
be decreasing before one so the function
is decreasing before one and increasing
after one well when is it minimal
one at one which means that the farmer
should go up to this point here which is
one kilometer dip the bucket and then go
to the car and you can even calculate
what you're gonna get
now
This is complicated if you don't know
these shortcuts or if you don't know
calculus is just impossible to
understand what I was doing
and if I change the numbers
two four and six to something else you
definitely don't want to redo this whole
computation you really need to know why
one is one
strictly speaking why should one be the
perfect number here in a more General
way okay and now comes our smart fifth
grader with another sheet of paper
perhaps Mr a cow is dying
ah yes yes yes
hold on the smart field grade is gonna
do it
back to square
one zero minus one square one square one
okay
so
why is this problem hard
suppose you don't know calculus and
Brady says he does not know calculus
so what will Brady do the problem is
hard
but for a very specific reason
can we simplify it can we create the
problem that looks almost identical to
this and it's actually trivial to solve
so what makes the problem hard
is that the farmer and the cow are on
the same side of the river
happen if just for a moment I told you
there is our River our cow and our same
numbers right ah I already see it
I mean what are you gonna do you'll just
take the straight
segment towards the cow yeah
so can we make our problem look like
this simple one
which operation will flip the farmer
across the river it's a reflection
so we're gonna reflect the real farmer
to a phantom farmer across the river
okay so this is going to be F Prime
still two kilometers from the river and
now Brady is thinking hold on doesn't
the river have with what happened to the
width of the river
who cares about it our original problem
is not affected by how wide the river is
correct
it's not at all and our world that we're
flipping across the river is just in our
imagination or on this paper so we are
the bosses I'm going to forget that the
river he's ready with
okay and so now we know very well what
the Phantom farmer must do the Phantom
farmer must go directly
to the cow and this point will be our
desired point x okay
what should the real farmer do what do
you think
should the real farmer go to the attack
so would that be the shortest path it
feels like it would be yeah it feels
like it should be and we claim that
indeed the farmer has to follow suit and
go to exactly the same point to which
the Phantom farmer would have come okay
how do you actually prove this okay I
want fifth grader would immediately
believe it but we have some doubts right
like how would you prove it
it's very simple any path that the real
farmer takes is mimicked by the Phantom
farmer so the whole set of paths for the
real farm are exactly the same in length
as the Phantom Farmer for instance let's
say the real farmer goes somewhere here
to point Y right and then to cow c well
is this the minimum task we will say no
because the Phantom farmer can mimic
this go to I and go to C and we see a
triangle F Prime y c and there's a
triangle inequality right so the
triangle inequality would say that the
two in this case drawn in black size F
Prime y plus y c is greater the sum is
greater than
the red side which is
Prime C
so this is not going to be the minimal
path because we already know that for
the Phantom farmer the red path is the
minimal and the real farmer has an
identical path in length to that one
so we conclude that whatever the Phantom
farmer is doing in length the real
farmer will mimic it on the other way
around and so the minimal path for the
Phantom farmer will be the minimal pair
for the real farm
and the only thing left here is to find
what this point x is without calculus we
already know that the number one should
appear for ax but we need now to prove
it okay and I need another picture not
long now cow not long
[Music]
we are almost there all right so where
is this point x
there are a number of triangles ready
how many triangles do you see uh one two
three four four but one of them is not
so interesting this this one here no but
let me just put dots this and this there
are three right angle triangles yeah in
this one and so they're not just the
right angle triangles they are relatives
those two are twins those are congruent
and the third one is similar to them all
right let me write this down triangle f
a x is congruent two triangle F prime a
x and those are similar to Triangle C B
X
that the smaller ones are congruent I
mean it's obvious they are reflections
of each other
uh why are they similar to the other one
they have one angle the same the right
angle but these two angles are also the
same they are vertical when two lines
intersect in a point the opposite angles
are always equal to each other okay and
by the way this angle here is also equal
to them as a reflection of the bottom
one so now we have three similar
triangles similar triangles are probably
the most ubiquitous tool used in solving
geometry problems they appear everywhere
now let us take the ratios of sides from
the top two triangles and I'm going to
use only the legs of those two right
triangles so I have 2 2X
so F A over a x which is 2 to X must be
equal on the other side
CB over BX
is the same ratio but in our notation CB
is six
and BX was the left over 4 minus X
and I think we're almost done because 2
and 6 cancel flip flop
4 minus X is 3x I believe we saw this
within the calculus solution
4 is equal to 4X x is equal to one
so indeed the farmer should walk one
kilometer down the river from a dip his
bucket in the water and go to C
much easier much easier
but it also reveals some geometry that
is related to
um stuff that we experience every day
for instance what happens if you have a
smooth surface very smooth like the
river and sunlight is coming to the
river at a certain angle ready any
memories from high school physics it
bounces so that the angle will be the
same on the other side correct yeah
okay so that's the sum here is this a
law is this a theorem what is it
I don't know it's just yes property of
nature yeah property of nature law of
nature right
well what the farmer is doing to reach
to the cow is exactly the same thing if
I change the numbers 2 4 6 to any other
numbers this property of equal angles
will be preserved because we will
exactly repeat the same solution well
with different numbers but the angles
will be equal
so the farmer is doing exactly the same
thing as the light is doing when
reflecting
but we showed something for the farmer
what did we show the farmer is following
the shortest possible path
so what is light doing when reflecting
therefore every time light reflects from
a surface the light is following the
shortest path
that's amazing so now which one is an
axiom a law of nature is it the law of
reflection or is it that the light is
always following the shortest possible
path it's it's mind-boggling but the
idea that mathematicians have is they
will assume that one is an axiom and
will prove the other one from it and in
this case it looks like they're actually
equivalent let me ask you a human
question
if if a farmer was standing there a real
Farmer and the cow was there the same
problem but he's got no mathematics he's
got
do you think he would aim for that point
do you think his Instinct would be to
aim for that one kilometer point or he'd
get it wrong I don't even think he would
have the measurements in front of him or
her no but if they were just walking
they would have said I've got they could
see it I could see the river I could see
the cow I've got to do this thing
do you think your instincts would fall
would would take you to the right place
I don't know about the farmer but there
is another calculus problem which is
about the dog
on the beach in a frisbee is thrown into
the water and so the dog has choices how
far to run on the beach and then how far
to swim and the dog wants to get to the
Frisbee as fast as possible but swimming
is slower than running exactly but maybe
it is too far from the water so it's
it's unclear and we can you know test
this on a dog and see what happens but
there is a familiar calculus problem
on that and let me and let me ask you
one more question you should you showed
me two ways to do it the calculus way
and then the the geometry on which was
so much more simple and it seemed
elegant to me does the calculus method
have any advantage over the geometry
like like if I is there is there is one
way better than the other for any reason
well they're better than each other for
different reasons
so for this particular type of problem
the geometrical solution definitely wins
in terms of Elegance
but if I make the problem more
complicated I may not be able to find
the geometric solution and then the
calculus solution will kick in what what
do you mean by complicated do you mean
no longer using you don't mean no longer
using integers because surely the
numbers don't really matter how could
you make it well maybe they would the
river would not be straight
that's one thing maybe the farmer has to
get water but also he has to get food
for the cow from somewhere else so you
can add more variation more variables
and the buckets heavier yeah that's
right and you know the whole thing
becomes an optimization problem and
that's what economists are there for
right
uh but um I do want to give you another
problem to try at home of course you do
there is a calculus solution and then
there is a super sweet geometry solution
and it's a it's a folklore problem well
we've been going for a little while so
the next problem we'll do in a separate
video links to that can be found on the
screen video description all the usual
places
and while you're in the video
description make sure you check out
links to our other videos with this
visitor and a podcast we recorded with
her where she basically tells her life
story it's really interesting his
theorem and I did not know about inverse